ocultos entre los muros de este hospital
parisino documentos históricos que el
público puede ver por primera vez este
hospital especializado en afecciones
oftalmológicas fue inaugurado en el
siglo 13 por el rey Luis noveno
antes
resulta muy emotivo encontrar las
instrucciones escritas que dio el rey
Luis hace más de 700 años y que
conciernen a un establecimiento que
Sigue atendiendo hoy en día a personas
que sufren deficiencias visuales
en las jornadas del patrimonio de este
año la atención se centra en explorar
los retos a los que se enfrentan estos
lugares de interés en función del cambio
climático este año muchas ciudades
también ponen el foco en mujeres
creadoras en el pasado el presidente
francés Emmanuel macron creó la lotería
del patrimonio hace cinco años a quién
queret un teatro del siglo 19 que lleva
cuatro décadas vacío recibirá 500.000
euros procedentes de esta iniciativa
desde el 2018 se han salvado 745 lugares
en peligro tanto en Francia como en el
extranjero por lo que es una campaña
extraordinaria que ha sido posible
gracias a esta lotería y que enriquece y
da visibilidad
asociaciones locales
en el programa se ha insertado además
una mirada entre los bastidores de notre
dame para observar las técnicas de
restauración que se utilizan tras el
devastador incendio de 2019